[Music]
our donor
my name is Papa and welcome to I almost
got there I want to do the dark Vader
thing the nurse can do it
first off I want to say thank you both
for 2,100,000 bro Spence crazy I don't
really have that much to say this week I
have more plan next week I'm sorry
so yeah I'm just gonna do a Q&A and from
Twitter so I asked the person Twitter to
ask me anything and we'll see what we
can find
so someone asked if they could see a
picture of me when I was child so here
you go
[Music]
but he's [ __ ] I didn't come on
right that's me how long have you been a
game there i don't know i don't i think
the term gamer is kind of Kennard I
don't know weird I think the first game
I play was ski free or pac-man remember
I freaking ski free is an amazing game I
think I'll do a let's play on that thing
all right breast this is ski free it's a
pretty shell game ah son of a [ __ ]
Hannah stark can you make a funny
montage yes I will awake funny I realize
has been way too long
and I'm sorry Carolee nice of the last
what describe like and I'll show you a
picture here
deae lover do you love making videos for
us of course I do I mean I started doing
this because I love doing it and keep
doing it because I love doing it dipper
pines can you draw yourself of course I
can I'll just [ __ ] draw someone
alright I guess it's time to show off my
my paint skills to draw myself we have
pretty it's my hair looks like a girl
[ __ ] I guess I got a just uh Sh but it's
this no okay let's get a six-pack in
there and my nipples
oh man boobs I am Edward Scissorhands
apparently where's my butt doing that
hey I don't have to but and then the
beard
that's 10 out of 10 lofty dinosaurs
what's your favorite type of sandwich
the one that your mama makes Oh red
Montero toughest game you play
I think Silent Hill is probably the most
difficult game or since senses freaking
hardcore [ __ ] man I need doughlas how
does it feel to have so many fans that
love you and care about you I feel
special I never felt special so thank
you guys
hidden Goomba asked me would I rather
have a stomach made of ducks for a head
made of cheese and I think I have a
pretty sexy stomach Denis elided I do
you like watching horror movies well
because he plays so many hurricanes my
girlfriend loves our movies so we watch
it a lot but I am I don't really like it
that much corruption oh how did you feel
when you gained to 20,000 times in one
night I had no idea I did that but
that's pretty cool I remember that one I
got a thousand subs during one night
that was when I had like 600 subscribers
and I got one of my videos posted on
another website and it was a huge deal
for me I remember my friend called me
and like 6:00 in the mornings and I shut
up I'm still a baby and then then I feel
like five minutes out like wait a minute
thousand subs so that was more of a big
deal for me getting started with you two
been getting such a huge following right
away
now 20,000 doesn't even mean anything to
me and you okay it's awesome okay here
we go
do you play the sports if you do then
what sport answer this in the last one I
play tennis and golf and ninety with a
little sailing every once in a while why
are you so Swedish if you see Slenderman
late at night what would you do I would
hug him and touch his butt lick his face
what you want
alright press that's it for me today
hope you have a nice weekend I'll be
keep playing video games for you and
programmer language for breakfast anyway
I want to do it I don't want anything
alright press down you know I love you
[Music]